hello everyone it's June 13th 23
and we're in cohort three
discussing chapter six
so we'll head over to the chapter six
page
and uh before we look at some of the
specific questions and like pick ones
that are interesting and so on
does anyone just want to give any
overall thoughts or questions
okay
well of course just write in the
chatter raise your hand
if you want
um we can
look to some of the previously addressed
uh or at least asked questions
and get some more perspectives and
improve some of the discourse
does anybody have a alternative
preference
all right so also definitely please vote
with a interesting button
because once we get above like 10 or or
some number of uh
votes then we'll make a short video so
we'll kind of be upvoting and then
seeking to improve those sections most
all right
why is modeling of the generative
process a necessary step for building an
active inference model
who wants to give a first thought on
this
that we can review but first just yet
Ali and then anyone else just why
why are we talking about modeling the
generative process
uh yeah I think as we talked about uh
the the distinction between General to
model and generative process before uh
well at least uh according to the
previous active inference framework
generative process is
uh basically what
um I mean it refers to the latent state
of uh the observery data we get from the
environment uh in other words uh what
causes those uh data uh in this case uh
is put into a kind of probabilistic
model so
on the other hand generative model
I mean the aim of generative model is to
provide a kind of mechanism to track
those uh generative process as close as
it can or at least
based on the situation of Interest so
that's one distinction between General
to model and generative process but on
the other hand
um well recently I
um got to the understanding that it's
not so straightforward to
separate generative model from General
to process as because in some situations
we might never know what generative
process uh
is I mean what it actually constitutes
generates a process and the only thing
we can concentrate or we can at least uh
confidently focus on is to model the
generative uh model based on uh some of
the
assumptions about how the environment
will
behave in the future or at least based
on some of our knowledge about the
overall mechanism of the environment
so but in some simple situations it
might be possible to
differentiate between the two
awesome thank you
anyone else have like any related
thought or question
about the role of building a generative
process in a generative model
and then we'll look at some of the
previous responses
and then we'll move on to another
question
okay I'll bring in one um paper path
integrals particular kinds and of course
remember that you can always just click
on the on the the icon of the institute
on the right and you'll jump to where we
are
um so in this paper which we often look
back towards
we see this
taxonomy of different kinds of things
ranging from the simplest inert systems
through active systems
but perhaps simple active systems like a
metronome
on through sophisticated or strange
systems
which have hidden internal states that
are doing like counterfactual kind of
world modeling self in World modeling
so in chapter six
we're talking about whether you're
trying to set up a simple inert system
or a simple octave system or you're on
the path towards making more complex
cognitive models
there's going to be certain steps that
are outlined in the recipe
so that is like the continuity of active
inference type modeling of the
particular partition
splitting things into internal external
and blanket States and then further
differentiating the blanket into the
incoming sensory States and the outgoing
action States
we're calling them sense and action is
of course
conditioned upon choosing one side of
that blanket to be internal and that's
kind of like the cognitive system of
interest and so we call the cognitive
system of interest in terms of its
particular States the internal and the
blanket States
that is like the thing
and that is the generative model
Ali
I get and one other related thing is I
mean this typology is actually based on
a three-level classification uh namely
at one hand we have the distinction
between active and inert particles which
do and do not have active States and
then on the other level we have
distinction with between dissipative and
conservative particles which are and are
not subject to random fluctuations and
finally the ordinary and strange
particles
um which have active states which do you
have and do not have active States and
one other point is it's interesting that
in some recent literature especially uh
the one the white paper published
um about four months ago ecosystems
designing ecosystems of intelligence
from first principles and this recent
paper
the inner screen model of Consciousness
the term generative process never appear
even once in the entire paper so
basically uh they they've began begun to
use a generative model interchangeably
with generative process in some sense
yes
um this is this is something that we're
gonna be
asking about
in guest stream 45 in six days
because we noticed that in this
presentation that Maxwell had generative
model covering the entire
particular partition
rather than the way that it was shown
in um the figures of the textbook
where we had the generative model
with internal and blanket States
essentially being partitioned from the
generative process which is the process
which actually gives rise to the
observations
so
we can think of it as kind of like some
uh
dialectical usage
in the dialect sense of the active
ontology so
Evolution and and use of what people are
referring to
um
that's how it goes when things are
changing fast but we'll find out in a
few days some more takes on this
um
active inference agent employs a
generative model as its model the
external world
and uses the generative model to perform
inferences about perceptual input to
make decisions about actions
the external world or the generative
process is complex and unknowable
generative models may or may not be able
to learn
but learning and also action selection
puts the generative model in better
alignment with the world's generative
process whatever it might be two ways to
minimize free energy change your mind
through perception and learning change
the world through action
and there's some more
discussion any other
for anyone
a comment or a question about the
generative process and the generative
model
and kind of where we're at in chapter
six or we'll move on to the next
question
all right awesome and also please use
the upvote so that we can just
figure out which questions we want to
make improvements and um short videos
around
okay
next question again please just raise
your hand if you have if you have a
different question or put it in the chat
so this is kind of a core
question about chapter six
what are the four steps in the recipe to
construct an active inference model
so
from the very first sentence of chapter
six
what the chapter is aiming to provide is
this four-step recipe to construct an
active inference model now it doesn't
have to be strictly linearly followed
they're more like four considerations
or four areas of questioning more so
than like you must take on one two three
four in this order
um
but
um let's look at the Active inference
model recipe we made just a sub page
because this is such a central topic
I mean all of our expectations and
preferences slash hopes and dreams
about applying active inference
using active inference modeling for some
system or phenomena of Interest
this is
kind of what it comes down to again this
isn't the only or the total
protocol for modeling but chapter six is
the
transition point in the book
where the first five chapters set us up
to understand epistemically what active
inference models were about
the low road and the high road in
chapters two and three how we approach
active inference
chapter 4 the generative model itself
and some of the mathematics and the
formalisms of it and then chapter five
exploring some applications in mammalian
neurophysiology and now chapter six is
like
our system of Interest whether it's
another aspect of mammalian
neurophysiology or whether it's any
other of the many many situations that
we're interested in modeling this is the
model recipe as laid out by the authors
here so does anyone want to give a
thought or a question or just overview
on the four
considerations that that are in chapter
six for the model recipe
yeah Ali and then anyone else
yeah just one thing uh that I think uh
We've also talked about before is to
keep in mind that it's not absolutely
necessary uh to follow those steps uh
strictly in a sequential order so it
would be possible to uh to address them
in at least uh in uh
an asynchronous way or even uh in some
cases even change the order of the steps
so it's just a general framework to
follow the recipe it's not I think needs
to be strictly observed
yeah maybe it's more like making four
dishes
but let's look at what they are
so first question which system are we
modeling
and this is
analogous to the identification of the
system of interest in systems
engineering
and there are situations where this is
trivial
or where the teacher tells you which
system is being modeled
but there's also situations where it's
non-trivial
because of course everything is attached
to everything in the world and so making
these distinctions about the spatial and
the temporal and the causal boundaries
of the system that we're actually going
to choose to model
such that it's at some base optimal
trade-off point between being tractable
and understandable implementable all of
these different features that's kind of
iterated process and that's not one
that's just simply written on the world
as it is so we just get to show up and
find out like this is where we have to
take an active approach to modeling to
even determine some of these processes
through inquiry but what which system
are we modeling
the um second question is what is the
most appropriate form for the generative
model so let's look at where they
describe this in a bit more detail
foreign
this is the decision whether it is
appropriate to think of a process in
terms of categorical or discrete
inferences
or continuous inferences
motivating the choice between discrete
or continuous time implementations or
hybrid of active inference so
just to recall figure 4.3
is where we see a juxtaposition of the
discrete time active inference
generative model on the top
and the continuous time active inference
generative model on the bottom
they're being laid out this way to
highlight their structural similarities
like they have this kind of downward
facing e and then the upstairs with
action in both cases
but there are some differences between
the discrete time and the continuous
time formulation
we're not going to go into too much more
detail on their differences right now
but we can discuss if people want and
this is going to get explored in a lot
more detail in chapters 7 and 8 the
coming two chapters
which are explicitly about discrete and
continuous time generated models
and you can also make hybrid
implementations so the most common
hybrid implementation
is um in the folk psychological setting
where decision making is discrete at a
higher level like should I um reach for
the the orange or the Apple
and then at the sensory motor or lower
smaller or faster level
you have a continuous time model like a
motor reflex model
and then the motor reflex model the
attractor of where it's going to be
expecting to find itself which is where
it reaches towards
is being imposed from the top down by
that categorical decision-making model
so Hybrid models are absolutely possible
and one setting that they're used in is
systems that have discrete
decision making processes that interface
with continuous sensory motor activities
then we need to select the most
appropriate hierarchical depth
motivating the choice between shallow
versus deep models
so
how much
spatial temporal or causal depth is the
model biting off
are you trying to model leather for one
season or for one year or for 20 years
or for a million years
and then how is that scope
going to be
compartmentalized into the model so
let's just say we wanted to do an 100
Year predictive model
one approach would be
um one tick of the model
one time step
in the discrete time model is a hundred
years and we fit all the parameters so
that they are like what's accurate after
100 years go by
but then we wouldn't be able to
necessarily make a prediction at 50
years so okay what else can we do we
could have the tick be one year and have
this model go 100 into the future
or we could have a nested model where we
have decades where the tick goes by one
year at a time and then 10 decades and
so at the higher nested level it's like
the transition between decades
and so these are all structural variants
of a model that can do prediction of 100
years or maybe you want every single day
maybe you want a transition Matrix
amongst seconds
but each of these are going to have
trade-offs in terms of the computational
requirements of the model
whether you're going to be able to
calibrate it with data the amount of
parameters that you're going to be
creating
and so this is the modeler's quest and
Art and Science to find the right
models
for a given situation because you know
all models are wrong some are useful
and finally we need to consider whether
it's necessary to endow the generative
model with temporal depth kind of
previously mentioned and the ability to
predict action contingent observations
to support planning
that's called planning as inference
and it is using the expected free energy
or if you have different actions that
can be taken different policies which is
kind of like an action over the given
time Horizon
then
planning as inference means predicting
the consequences of those actions and
then doing a type of inference to
determine which path of action to be
taken
after determining the form for the
generative model
there are the questions of setting up
the generative model and setting up the
generative process
so
the kernel of active inference if we see
it in figure 4.3 again the discrete time
or the continuous time
this doesn't have
attention metacognition
um
learning of preferences
counterfactual World modeling what would
happen if they did that
there's a lot of sophisticated cognitive
phenomena that are not found in the base
model in fact the base model doesn't
even have learning at all
we're going to see in the coming
chapters how this can be
straightforwardly elaborated to include
learning on any parameter shown here
but this by itself does not include
learning
and so they're they're highlighting
that there's a lot of decisions to be
made
in terms of setting the priors
and which aspects are going to be fixed
and what aspects are going to be
learnable and remember that the models
are maps not territories so just because
something is learnable
in principle or in practice in the real
world
doesn't necessarily mean that the model
is going to be simply mimicking that
and vice versa
so again these are just some steps to
consider
essentially setting up
the generative model and the generative
process
the the type of thing that we're
modeling the cognitive entity and
their environment
and they say that these four steps in
most cases suffice to design active
inference model
once completed the behavior of the
system is determined by the standard
schemes of active inference
this is a huge advantage of working with
active inference cognitive modeling
is once you get the model set up
and entered into whatever implementation
approach you're using SPM or Pi mdp or
RX infer Etc
then
the methods of parameterizing it
fine-tuning it fitting that model
are very generic and straightforward
so it's not like you kind of slap
together how you're thinking about the
system and then you're going to spend
all of this engineering work on making
the optimization
tractable
it's the opposite
a lot of the work goes into
a structural understanding of the system
because once you have your model entered
in
to Pi mdp for example
then standard routines are used to fit
the model
Ali than anyone else
uh yeah I'm wondering uh how I mean to
what extent uh this recipe is applicable
when it comes to modeling the collective
intelligence which is uh I mean the
current interests of active inference
research largely uh and in particular I
believe based on the stages of
development proactive inference outlined
in designing ecosystems white paper
currently we're under systemic
intelligence level of modeling and we're
aiming toward modeling or toward
developing an efficient way to model a
sentient intelligence but we're not
there yet
on the uh problem of modeling
sophisticated intelligence and
sympathetic and
ultimately shared intelligence so it's
interesting to see how those four steps
can be applied when when we finally get
into those stages of development of
active impress agents
yes this is from the paper from 2022.
Olivia
yeah oh so I suppose that you know the
best way to understand these four
different points is to uh look at how
you know uh current examples or papers
uh have done them
uh so take you know already implemented
models uh and identify you know uh step
one two three and four
um and you know do we have in uh in the
active Enterprise textbook groups uh
some kind of uh you know list of
um example models to do that yes
yes absolutely so it's a it's a great
suggestion though I agree that um
showing these stages being carried out
we can hope becomes
a practice in the active inference
ecosystem because it would connect a lot
of the dots for people replicating the
analyzes and for learners but here's
what we can look at now in the code page
we have several dozen
different languages different
implementations of active inference
drawn from a variety of uh papers pretty
much the GitHub pulled out where we can
now not all these are heavily documented
or pedagogically oriented
so sometimes there's some forensic work
to be done with like understanding
um because and also a lot of this
happens outside of the context of shared
epistemic niches and shared education so
the variables are going to have
different names and the implementations
are going to be quite different these
are not necessarily created
um after reading chapter six especially
if they yeah but but it certainly is a a
retroactive approach that can describe
um and then I think one of the most
clearly unpacked and didactic examples
that we can look at is uh model stream
7.2
and in model stream 7.2 in the
video description is The Notebook
of this
presentation
and so it does in a much more
pedagogical way and in an executable way
it runs perfectly as is
you can see
how is B getting set up
so again this isn't exactly aligned with
the four stages of the recipe but but
like we said those don't have to have in
that order but this is like these are
the variables that you need to set up a
b c d e
yeah and then at the bottom you see the
routines
the Run active inference Loop
so if seeing it in a pseudo code way
helps you understand the perceptual
nature of the active inference Loop
better than the analytical equations
that's definitely a good way to learn
and study this
okay yeah great
any more that we can say on this
one other resource I'll link in there
this is to the octave block friends
um Coda this is another project at The
Institute so here we we've kind of
expanded on the recipe
to include
more up front and along the way
so more of like the structural
understanding of the system and why the
model is being made then
we kind of include the steps of chapter
six
but also take more of a life cycle
perspective on the operations of these
models
and then we have all these different
settings where people have started to
explore
those kinds of modeling approaches so
I'll just link to this page also um
in in the recipe
okay
let's go back to the questions
so what are the four steps
we just looked through them essentially
they're a set of considerations
that build the generative model the
generative process so the cognitive
thing and the environment the niche
that's giving observations
for considerations that help us develop
that from its kind of sketchiest
outlines on through the determination of
which variables are going to be like
learnable or not which ones are discrete
State space which one's our continuous
State space Etc and then once we have
that set up
and entered into our implementation
approach
then all the routines are standard
and there's always exciting developments
with making those routines better at
dealing with sophisticated
um planning and so on
so again this is a big strength and a
growing one for active inference
that the work in understanding the
system
gets us to the point where it can be run
generically
as opposed to just taking an ad hoc
understanding of a system which is like
kind of a mistake but one that flies by
in many situations
and then confusing the engineering work
with improving the computational aspects
of the model
with an understanding of the system
okay
so that was this question
again upvote the question so they rank
higher but I'm just going to continue
down from the top
um in figure 6.1
what do the unidirectional and
bi-directional arrows mean
so we see there are some connections
between nodes nodes are random variables
and edges represent causal influences
possible causal influences
just because they're here doesn't mean
that they're relevant in a given
situation
but this is kind of like the set of the
possible connectivities
of the action perception Loop
so
the blanket states are connected to each
other
possibly because they form that
insulating set around the internal
States
so again you can design a system where
the API call comes in and then a second
computer computes it and then a third
computer emits it
so there doesn't have to be an edge
between these two
but in principle it's allowable
um
we see this symmetry
where again an internal and external
that just depends which system we're
focusing on but there's a symmetry
across here so you can kind of see it's
like a rotated 180 degree symmetry where
sensory states don't have a backwards
Arrow from internal States
and external states don't have a
backwards Arrow to active States
however external and sensory have
bi-directionality and internal action
have bi-directionality so
um
the particle
that which is being partitioned off from
the world
can have different
sensory and active blanket States
blanket being the joint set of U and Y
and internal States
and these arrows are just shaping out
the space of the possible interactions
amongst those variables
and
um in
let's see guest stream
number seven
how particular is the physics of the
free energy principle
if people want to go into more detail on
this question
uh Miguel Aguilera and colleagues
provided some technical analyzes and
basically asked under what topologies of
the action perception Loop
does the free energy principle apply
for example if we have like a simple
around-the-clock model
none of these backwards arrows do things
still apply
or if we have more or less connectivity
in in principle what applies
and um the short answer to this is
basically it's always going to hold in
some fashion but it may or may not be
interesting
and the important constraints
that we're really adhering to
the most important constraint is
across the interface
there's no telepathy and there's no
telekinesis
that doesn't mean internal States
can't track or phase lock onto external
states with very sparse sensory input
the point is they do so only through the
blanket so you can't get information
about hidden States except by sensory
States that's no telepathy clause
in the no telekinesis Clause is you can
only influence external States
through the octave States the blanket
so the fact that there's no connection
between internal and external States is
really the most important constraints on
the topology of
perception and action and active
inference and other than that there's
some technical discussions to be had
about exactly
um which situations have bi-directional
arrows and so on and some of it is
explored in 7.1
Ali and then anyone else
I just want I wanted to mention a couple
of technical terms
um that being used in the literature
repeatedly one is the autonomous states
which refers to
um The Joint set of internal States and
the activist States instead of the whole
blanket state so particle is the joint
set of internal States and the whole
blanket States but if we consider only
the active States among the blanket
States then that's been referred to
autonomous States and the other term is
a sparse coupling which exactly refers
to that unidirectional Arrow
in this figure so very briefly sparse
coupling
refers to the fact that things are
defined by what they are not connected
to so if the whole
diagram here would be connected the
whole states here would be connected
through bi-directional errors then that
would just that wouldn't be a sparse
coupling so the reason this term is used
is because of that unidirectionality in
the speaker
awesome
and one important piece on the
autonomous States and this is kind of
like a cool way to think about active
formally but also informally
autonomous States again are just the
internal and active States so these are
the two ways that you can reduce your
free energy change your mind change the
world through action learning a
perception update internal States action
updating active States
our preferences the C Vector are over
sensory States
so we say I prefer to find myself at 37c
homeostatic body temperature
and so because I prefer that I'm going
to seek policies that
Meander my way even if it's one step
backwards Two Step forwards
to reduce my surprise bound my surprise
reduce my expected free energy about
finding myself at homeostatic body
temperature so our preferences are over
sensory States
but the two things that we can control
the autonomous States
like all knowing and all-powerful
are the internal and active States
and another way of saying that is you
don't directly have your thumb on the
scale
we want to see a certain number on the
but all we want to be able to do even in
our maximal empowerment would be perfect
updating of learning and perception and
perfect selection of action
if you enable the model to also take
control over its sensory incoming data
not the not the downstream processing of
it but the primary sensory data
then the model May ins in pursuit of
seeking its preferences just simply
modify the sensory data
so
if we'd like to see a sunset you know we
want to either learn but we're not
seeing one we want to either learn that
we actually don't prefer that
then all is good with the world or make
a plan to see it
but if you can just turn on the VR
in your mind and see it right there
you've kind of
um
made a hollow satisficing of your
preferences
and in the ecological evolutionary
context you're going to get swept off
the table
so the autonomous states are like what
we would want to control under maximal
empowerment and they're the two Avenues
of reducing free energy changing mind
and changing the world
Olivier
yeah I mean uh I'm not sure I got it uh
but you you said the preference is put
on the sensory uh state
correct yeah uh so
if that
um reflected in the mathematical uh
expression of free energy
oh absolutely it is not shown here this
on a particular partition we don't see
the C vector or preferences but um let's
look at it in the equations
so here equation 2.6
on expected free energy
and so
in the top decomposition
expected free energy G is a function
that's evaluating policies so it's
loading in our policy prior that's like
our habits
and then it's sharpening those policy
priors into a policy posterior
that then you can sample from or just
select the best option from
so let's just say that um two-thirds of
the time I turn left that's my habit
and then if we just passed the prior on
policy through then action would be
selected according to that ratio
two-thirds the time going to the left
however what expected free energy does
is it sharpens the policy prior habit
into policy posterior in the top
decomposition
we see one way of thinking about what
contributes to the expected free energy
for a given policy concern or option and
that's thinking about it in terms of the
information gain and the pragmatic value
so first The Information Gain here we
see that there's a KL Divergence between
hidden States Through Time X tilde
Pi is on both sides and here there's a y
so if the Y the expected sensory
information under that policy if it
didn't give us any information it's not
expected to give us information then the
KL Divergence is zero
no information is expected to be gained
from that course of action however if
the policy does have a sensory
observations that would lead us to learn
then epistemic gain is non-zero
here we have pragmatic value
and this is basically how surprised are
you
about the sensory data given your
preference
and so if your preference is 37 and it's
like a bowl around 37 then the highest
pragmatic value policy
would be the least surprising meaning
that the ball would be right at the
bottom of the bowl at 37.
so just to contrast with reward learning
reinforcement learning
in reward and reinforcement learning you
have this reward function that's like 37
is the most rewarding body temperature
so I'm going to try to find my way up to
the most rewarding point
we take an opposite approach we say I
expect and prefer to be at 37c
that's what I'd be least surprised by if
my thermoreceptors were at 37.
that's why expectations and preferences
are kind of used together in that way
and then policies are selected
that are able to
um
contribute to pragmatic value and
Information Gain
and during the modeling process you see
that there are some fine tuning
needed to balance these two drives and
that's actually explored in this
notebook like if you set the preference
for getting sugar to 1 million to one
then it'll never seek information it's
ready to risk it for the chance of
winning a million but if the pragmatic
value is um very small then the
Information Gain term dominates
and another way that that is shown in a
figure
is in figure 2.6 where we have expected
free energy just as shown now here the
pragmatic value term is on the left but
it's the same equation yeah and so if
only pragmatic value matters so it's a
fully observable there's nothing
epistemic to gains like a chessboard
then you get expected utility Theory
in contrast when there's no pragmatic
value on the table so all outcomes are
equally pragmatically valuable then you
only have two three four five
in which case you're having information
driving decision making
yeah
but both can be on the table and that is
how octave inference in a first
principles way is negotiating the
explore exploit dilemma
yeah
thank you
Ali thanks
and also this kind of information
seeking or a preference seeking is what
referred to as
curiosity or rather artificial curiosity
in the literature but it's probably
worth mentioning another recent Trend in
active inference literature which is the
development of sophisticated active
inference
which I don't think is
explicitly stated in the textbook but
basically sophisticated inter inference
um
deals with the situations in which
rather than
trying to answer what will happen if I
do this they try to address what will I
believe if I do this so basically
it's it's based on the consequences of
actions for beliefs rather than just the
states of the world
thank you
yeah especially with all of the
developments and elaborations happening
like around the time of the writing of
this textbook and since then
um
it's kind of It kind of contextualizes
the bigger picture but like figure 4.3
is like the Lego block
this is like the the neutral minimal
cognitive kernel
shown in its discrete time and
continuous time setting
and a lot of the work right now on the
analytical and on the formal side for
example with category Theory
is to understand the compositionality of
these models like can we really attach
this to that
in principle
and then a lot of the computational work
which you'll see
um in the code section
are using techniques from computer
science broadly
like search on large trees and branching
and pruning on trees
using these computer science and
engineering approaches to make running
large active inference models more
tractable
so the textbook helps us um
parachute in
and get a first overview
but
for those who want to see more there's
certainly more on the computer science
implementation side and on the
analytical on the formal side
but all things considered the textbook
s the line
between that
and again chapter six is like the moment
in the book where it transitions from
the first five chapters
which are like a background and
statistics class
on through chapter six and Beyond which
through our work we can even develop
into something like a A playbook
or a set of code and and in cohort three
which we're in right now with chapter
six one of our goals for this activity
interval
is to leave an executable Trail
so we want to develop the answers
to questions
but also especially where we can to
um
leave a code
or executable or just pseudo code
way to approach this
and that's something that can be
collaboratively worked on inversion
through the cohorts
okay a few more questions
all right how does the particular
partition so figure 6.1
particular partition the particle
blanket and internal States autonomous
States just internal and active but the
particle imagine if you're looking at a
dust particle under the microscope
that would be an inert particle but a
cognitive particle is like the agent in
the agent-based modeling
so we see sometimes
a simple action perception Loop
and other times we see the the more um
expanded
particular physics
but then
this question asks
how does the particular partition relate
to the partially observable Markov
decision process in figure 4.3
so where did the Markov blanket go in
figure 4.3
okay one simple thought that anyone can
add more the observations here oh
are the sensory States
and so in the continuous time they're
even shown with Y so that's actually the
same variable as used for sensory States
and the particular partition
but the O are the observables
across the markup blanket and then here
Pi's policy selection policy inference
which is influencing the B Matrix which
is how the agent thinks things change
Through Time
but we could also Imagine That Pi also
reaches out to influence the generative
process which just isn't shown here
here just the agent's generative model
is shown
there's no generative process but if
there were a generative process it would
be
receiving an input from PI
and sending an output to observations
so the pomdp can be seen as like a way
of unrolling
the particular partition
because this gives a um sequential
linear executable format
to modeling the particular partition
any other thoughts on this
Ali
uh yeah one other way to like look at it
is to interpret the uh I mean because in
sorry in pomdp uh the a the agents
preferred observations
um
somehow strives toward keeping it within
the high probability States uh which
would be consistent uh with its
continued existence in other words uh
this uh striving toward uh keeping these
hyper probability States can be
interpreted as keeping uh its markup
blankets marker blanket intact so in
other words markup blanket is kind of
implicitly
um implied in Palm pmdp but not uh
obviously explicitly stated but it can
be interpreted
from various perspectives
yes thank you
okay
gibsonian affordance concept
does anyone want to give a little
information on this question and then I
think we'll have a response
well it's a controversial issue indeed
yeah if you can just briefly uh yeah
remind uh Gibson's affordance concept
yes
okay yes let me get the
right page here
okay here I'm going to
um
share some work by Paulo an intern
and he's analyzing
the affordance concept and the
representation Concept in the English
and in the Portuguese literature using
the active inference ontology to to
connect between the two of them
um and there's a table
so recently there was a um paper written
by ramstead
about the affordance 3.0 concept
and basically says the way that we talk
about affordance is an active that is
pretty much the gibsonian affordance
concept
so as of the
um tactfully noted this is like an area
of discussion slash controversy so I
look forward to Apollo developing the
work more and and bringing this out
however
affordance 1.0 concept by Gibson
was that the affordance was about the
perception of a capacity for action in
the environment like a handle is
perceived as for grasping
and people focus a lot on this direct
perception and there's the whole Markov
blanket trick which we've talked about
elsewhere and people focus on like
whether the Marco blanket is direct or
indirect perception but that is actually
a little bit of a red herring
the key piece of the gibsonian
affordance concept is that the
affordance is doing something
explanatory about perception it's
explaining a perception of a certain
type which is the perception for action
in the niche
however inactive inference as it's been
used
affordance
is used to describe
action capacities that are not
necessarily perceived
more like something that the system can
do
and so when we look at the pi variable
from like figure 4.3
then like we call those a for what we
call E affordances and then Pi is the
policies of affordances so if it's just
one time step then Pi is the same as e
but if it's uh 12 time steps then it's
all the 12-step combinations of the
affordances
e what can be done
however active inference does not
highlight the perceptual aspects of the
affordance
because it's kind of a view from the
inside view from the outside which we're
going to come back to in chapter nine
but just to show what this looks like
the experimenter might say well that
Mouse can go up down left right
so that's how the active inference
affordance concept is used up down left
right are the four capacities for action
however the traditional ecological
psychological
gibsonian affordance concept highlighted
the view from the inside which is the
perception of an action capacity
now that's not a perfect Concept in and
of itself because it just begets the
next question well what raises
Salient affordances to awareness
so it's not like one is better than the
other
and surely they can be understood of as
compatible
however there is some significant work
needed to understand the continuity of
these Concepts
and whether or not it's valid to say
that the affordance 3.0 concept is
actually in the direct lineage of the
affordance 1.0 and 2.0 concept
and Paulo s is the best intern to speak
to about this topic
cool
well
that brings us to the um
end here
I'll unlike these ones
for uh next week will be at the other
time
and um yeah everyone's welcome to add or
upvote questions
or anything else any anyone else want to
add anything before we close
awesome thank you yes chapter six is
when it really starts getting into the
the modeling and the doing
so also next week I'll I'll hope that we
can
um
develop out some of the code maybe even
annotate some of the
um the pi MTP examples or some of the
other examples in terms of the recipe
okay
thank you all farewell
thank you
thanks bye